hey everybody and welcome to a very
fun wild ride with stevo we're talking
to chanel west coast
you know and you love her from
ridiculousness and
we're gonna find out if she's happy with
what she's being paid
oh did i say that yep i did
let's get into it ladies and gentlemen
chanel west coast what's up
yeah see where am i looking up there
right oh you look wherever you want
maybe it's just gorgeous man scott
randolph nice to meet you nice to meet
you
and up at the front we've got the
gorgeous paul briskey hi chanel nice to
meet you
nice to meet you too yeah and and thank
you for doing this we're neighbors
i know we are it's so crazy i was like i
wonder if you saw me
walking by or something like oh she
should be on the podcast
um i have seen you i drive by your house
like
uh every i can't go anywhere without
yeah it's like the only way out of here
right was that your first home yes
i forget how i found out that that was
your house i feel like maybe my
someone told my girl and we were driving
by my girl said oh that's you know west
coast and i thought cool
yeah a lot of people found out because i
threw a party
during the pandemic and then it was like
yeah everybody kind of found out i saw
that on tmz that's where i get my news
yeah some somebody sent the some [ __ ]
who was
in my party sent the video to tmz and
i'm just like okay i've gotta
be way more strict with my guest list
next time yeah
afterwards or during the party uh during
the party they
they from in my living room took a video
and then sent it to tmz yeah and you
know who it was
no i don't know who was oh damn yeah i
was pissed
guy hickey yeah he can find out yeah we
gotta track this person down make sure
they're not on the list
we were just putting it out there we
were super
coveted safe like it was so that day not
one person walked in without getting
their temperature checked every single
person passed the temperature check
isn't that the point of those things
i remember this party because like
this party none of the party that she's
talking about it was like
noon they were like 11 in the morning
like
like and there were insane amounts of
trucks they were bringing in like all
kinds of like it was like a
big ass like party yeah i take my
parties really serious
um but i guess i was wasn't supposed to
take my party seriously during a
pandemic
yeah wow the trucks were kind of like
catering trucks
yeah you know just like i'm all about
the decorations
and like having like fun little games
for people to play at the party and
stuff like that
did anybody try to use your black paper
towels at the party
i'm [ __ ] down for those and i don't
know why they don't have different
colored towels
period they should be more common um i
love the black paper towels the only
thing that sucks is like if you're
trying to like clean up something dirty
you can't see like how good you've
cleaned it up on the black
so you actually use them yeah yeah i do
not as much but
they're like my backup ones for when we
run out of the regular
where did we learn about the black paper
towels there was a nikki swift video
i don't know who nikki swift is but
she's my biggest fan
no it was like this is pretty big on
jackass
too yeah no it's like you did a cribs
for this new house right
oh my god it came out well apparently
yeah maybe it came out like yesterday
and i just
wait wait wait they're doing mtv cribs
yeah they just started doing it again
wow so where does it live on mtv like
and youtube and everything yep
yeah i didn't know it dropped that's
crazy wait what's up with these black
paper towels
are they just black paper towels or is
there something else going on they're
folded up like napkins no no no no no no
no
no no it's like i mean black paper
towels okay it's a roll of paper towels
and it's just black
yeah that's sick as [ __ ] yeah i don't
know why they were and they
it's like they work just like regular
paper towels i mean
like i said it's just if you're trying
to clean up something dirty you can't
see like how good you've cleaned it up
on the black
right it is satisfying to look at that
thing be like yeah i clean all that off
the counter
like that's nice oh [ __ ] that was dirty
you know
you have to like hold it up to a
blacklight you're like oh wow i prefer
like uh like like black sinks black
marble black toilets like but i think
black toilets are the best
yeah so you can't really see anything if
you have guests over you know that's so
funny i
just chipped the marble in
our living room by throwing pool balls
at the at the tv and uh
uh-huh and so like i would like to redo
it
yeah my girls bummed that i chipped this
thing so i got a
maybe black marble is the ticket black's
kind of sick yeah
i love like yeah and it's you know black
all black everything
my girl loves all black everything too
yeah but i feel like it's an opportunity
to further
your love for for lux to redo more of
the
i know that's what i'm talking about
yesterday i accidentally broke the tv
and i'm like [ __ ] it now we get to
really break it and uh and then get a
better tv
yeah and so it's like the same same
thing with the [ __ ]
marble that i chipped you know like lux
is all bent out of shape i said babe
let's get
get a better one
yeah get some sledgehammers i mean
here's the thing and like
we uh i just started making like weekly
vlog videos which seemed like totally
counterintuitive
to me and my style of art in that like
follow me around into my personal life
you know and i thought okay
screw it i'm gonna do it and then and
then before we even made
one of these videos i realized okay now
every week i have to do something heavy
every week i have to do something super
heavy but like i mean we look at these
people like
david dobrik a few months ago like
that the paul brothers roman the people
who like really regularly put up these
videos
are killing it man i want to be killing
it me too
i'm like dude this [ __ ] youtube [ __ ]
i'm like i've been like
like like i just yeah yeah i'm like
i need to film everything that's what i
realized because like my life's crazy
and all these crazy things happen and
like
that's that's like exactly what i want
to do i'm like dude these guys are just
like famous from like just documenting
like
anything you know what i mean but it's
because they're so
on top of doing it it's so much work
it is a lot of work it's so much work
but the guy
casey was like look dude it was like the
worst thing that ever happened in my
life i was doing it every day like i
shut out all my friends that weren't in
the scene and and like what we gathered
from that i was like yeah dude like you
probably don't want to do it
like immediately after steve's like okay
so we're gonna be doing daily vlogs
like that's what you got from that that
was your takeaway like
right but but i quickly realized that
every day is is
just not in the interest of making the
videos kick ass
i figured do one every week yeah just
just every week
every week we do one podcast a week we
do one [ __ ]
crazy vlog video yeah some casey's buddy
would be like you want to get dinner
he's like you're not
in this next scene i can't have dinner
with you or yet
sorry yeah for sure um
so when we were watching this thing they
said like how
like of course you've got your rap
career yeah you've got all these
initiatives with like
clothing brands and and uh what like
what what are you
doing best with like for uh for business
these days
uh well now that things are opening up
my music uh because my music's finally i
feel like
i've been doing music forever i got on
rob's show by doing music but people
know me more you know for being on his
shows
but when you came on the show you came
on the show saying
like i'm a rapper yeah yeah yes i rap
and sing i'm
i got into music by rapping because i
didn't really like know how to write
singing songs so i started writing raps
and then
um yeah i sing too so like i've you know
now i think
what do you prefer i prefer wrapping
just because like i can write a wrap in
my sleep i can't
a singing song takes more time okay it's
a lot more
to put into it you know like like
melodies you know thinking of all the
different melodies like a rap is a poem
over a beat like and i've done poetry
since i was
seven whenever they taught you about all
the little poems in like third grade or
whatever like
i got into it that was a hobby of mine i
always wrote little poems
and then um i was a dancer so like
naturally like i was like okay
poetry hip-hop dance rapping
all right good is that onomatopoeia what
is onomatopoeia
no i think onomatopoeia has a word that
sounds like the sound it's describing
that's totally different like buzz or
zip
that's you so i just blew that yeah i
don't think you're not a rapper's guy
i'm not a rapper
and neither am i did you ever hear about
when i was trying to be a rapper
i didn't oh you didn't no how did this
go under the radar
i don't know either what was this i know
we're oh eight
it was uh it was 2007 2008
and i had a [ __ ] record deal with
universal music
really he was killing it yeah and uh
and it was to make a comedy gangster rap
album
and i uh was super on drugs and it got
like too much like that
like it got too much i was on drugs for
it to really be be
cool yeah but now i want to get my rap
redemption
i have a feeling that if i make new rap
music it is going to be
murderous and speaking of murderous
there's a company called liquid death
that i am truly in love with man you're
going to see me drinking this stuff all
the time
because it turns out water is really
good for you and this is mountain spring
water they also
have sparkling water in cool ass
tallboy cans that look like beers it's
just a lot
of fun and i love the company
why because plastic it's like not even
really recyclable anymore somehow that's
what i'm hearing
and these cans are infinitely recyclable
so you're doing a good thing
for the world you're doing a good thing
for your body
and you look pretty cool doing it
because these cans are
hella dope so i want you to try it man i
want you to get behind this company
because i personally love them and to do
so
you're gonna go to liquid death dot com
slash stevo and when you do that you get
a free set of koozies with your first
order of
any case of water so again you're gonna
do this
to help me out to help you out and to
get behind this company because they
kick ass
you're gonna go to liquid death.com
stevo and you're to enjoy a free set of
koozies with your first order of any
case
yeah dude now let's talk about rap music
so i'm trying to like like maybe record
a track or maybe even like a whole thing
like a whole album i don't know what
came first the uh the bloods and crips
tattoo or the rap
album or is it like the same you have a
blessing
[Laughter]
was that like the other side
when was that like was that like your
rapping or was that way before you
wanted to do this
i'm so bummed that you asked that
because i'm so fat i'm so sorry
i don't know what i'm doing with my life
at this point it's it's all good man
um okay so uh so with the music
do you have like albums coming out and
stuff yeah uh well i just dropped the
album
in november and it's called america's
sweetheart
very fitting i feel like i i've named it
that because literally
when i'm in the airport when i'm like
traveling i hear that term
so like people like oh my god you know
you're like america's sweetheart you
know you're like america's sweetheart
right
i watch you on tv every day all day
you're america's sweetheart
and like so many people say that to me i
was like okay i wanna
i wanna use that title but also show
that like being a sweetheart you can
also be like a badass [ __ ] at the same
time you know you can be sweet and you
can be tough
all right so it's kind of like oxymoron
because obvi like i have a song called
pull up with too short it's literally
talking about fighting the whole song
but i'm america's sweetheart you know
good
yes um so
how many albums do you have the the um
so that's like my
i put out two mixtapes i called them
mixtapes we put them out for free
initially so that's why they're called
mixtapes but they were basically albums
like
my first my first one i dropped um
god i can't remember how many songs i
always put out like a long mixtaper
album like i believe
like that's how it should be you know i
feel like a project shouldn't be like
six songs like it's so weird how these
albums these days are like six songs
like that's not an
album that's like a week like an album
it's a little package
yeah like it's like 20 songs you know so
my first
mixtape was like 19 songs i think or
something like that my second one was
like 15 or 16 songs
and then my last my now first album was
19 songs
when did the first one drop 2013.
okay yeah how long does it take to make
an album depends
it depends like i mean this album i put
out in november i had half the album
already done for like
two or three years i shouldn't say that
though if i want to try to win a grammy
because there's like a expiration date
on songs apparently
not if you're lil wayne yeah right
the carter five like how long did that
[ __ ] get held up
we heard about that for years and years
and years yeah
yeah there's a lot of situation i was
actually with young money
there's a lot of complications like with
all so i said so your uh
your new album american sweetheart
america's
america's sweetheart it didn't come out
from lil wayne's
young money no i put it out uh
independently okay cool good for you i
feel like that's the way right
yeah why wouldn't you right well during
the pandemic it was great because i
noticed i'm like
why is there like the first couple
months of pandemic i'm like there's like
no new music and i'm like oh my god
these
it's like you can do everything from
home like they're everybody's still
working from home but i guess the labels
were kind of
shut down or whatever so i'm like this
is the time
put your [ __ ] out you know because i
realized like oh that's what the hold up
is
all the offices are closed so for the
first like three months of the pandemic
there was literally like no new music
everything that was out those first
couple months had just dropped right
before lockdown
or was an independent artist so um so
that's why i was like i need to hurry up
and finish up my album get it out
because it was like the perfect time as
an independent artist to just like drop
mad [ __ ] i have nobody holding me up i
can do whatever i want you know yeah
i i put out my my news special on uh
during the pandemic your dog is so she
was like i was looking at
look at her you remember i had wendy
with me when i was on
ridiculousness last time and she was so
good she's like
she was like made for camera i know
she's the best
so uh so so how recently did america's
sweetheart come out
in november november you said that and
uh you put it out independently
so like what what's the ratio between
like
physical cds and like just
downloads i i have not even put out a
physical cd size it's probably all
downloads
it makes preparations you know what
though i need to um so that's what
somebody told me to see like i'm
independent i don't even know these
things and my friend was like
we gotta get um like a merch package
going with hard
cds because that's where like that's
where you can get a lot of sales and
chart and that's what i guess a lot of
people have done
like to like trick the system because
people don't really buy records like
they used to so
now they do like travis scott did it a
bunch of different people they do these
like merch packages where
you buy the cd with it and that counts
as a sale for the cd
for sure right there's a bunch of
different ways to game the system like
that
yeah who is it uh yeah we're just
talking to logic i feel like prince
had a lot of controversy with that like
you you got to see when you bought a
ticket to his tour
you got a cd with it oh wow yeah so he's
just selling
stadiums worth of cd 50 000 a night
um we can definitely help with the the
merge situation
like uh scott's my merch guy oh okay
we started working yeah we started
working together like seven years ago
and uh i had like three products i had a
book and a t-shirt i had two products
yeah and uh and now i've got so many
conglomerates i have so many [ __ ]
products it's ridiculous the book
falls on i've cuz i want to do a book
too but that's
that's you do that too he does the
publishing but then we'll we'll
sell it online and all that yeah once i
once i became
an author and then i'm a new york times
bestseller
now i'm also like a book seller because
i buy books from the publisher okay for
like with an author discount
so i get like i get a pretty good deal
like as if i'm a store
and then and then i sign every single
book like by hand
yeah and and i make every single
signature
look like a dick and then i sell them on
my website
so we sell all this stuff on my website
and for the longest time we had
uh like some other random company like
fulfilling our orders
yeah you know and we just thought that
was stupid at a certain point so we got
our own warehouse
like our own warehouse staff and uh and
it's a fulfillment center
so absolutely you should get physical
copies of your cd and then
sign them because people aren't going to
want the [ __ ] disk what's going to be
meaningful to them is like i've got
this signed you know and when you sign
it you can definitely charge more for it
and when you go to like shows just sign
them
yeah sell them after your shows for sure
and have all kinds of merch i do i'm
well right now i'm revamping my line um
lol cartel
i'm revamping it and like i had it in
zoomies and then
it was like right when i was getting it
going really good the pandemic happened
and then
zoomies like all their stores shut so
they weren't taking any new stuff
onto the shelves they're like whatever
we have we're just trying to sell right
now
so that put my line on hold but now
everything's opening again and so i'm
putting out a whole new line of my line
i don't know how you say
is that is zoomies open again yeah and
you're in there
yep that's where we're coming up short
is on the retail side
yeah i know i know you'd be killing it
as zoomies especially with your decks
because you've got skateboard decks that
they're just oh
what happened to wood cause that's a
sick name
it was a sick name uh that's a long
story
we don't have to get into it but i just
i'm dying to know because that's like
i mean it makes sense yeah it makes so
much sense um
it just didn't work out let's just put
it that way like
i i think it was just too premature for
me to have my own line type thing
like i was still like the receptionist
on rob show people were like you're
a receptionist with your own clothing
line yeah but didn't
didn't uh drama put out the the young
and the reckless
yeah that was that was like the [ __ ]
most explosively huge [ __ ] out he
blew that the [ __ ] up for sure the
funniest was we were at coachella one
year and like
all these wasted people like the young
and the restless like everywhere we go
just yelling young and the restless and
he's like it's reckless
reckless but they like all these wasted
people all day not one person said
reckless they're just like
the young and the restless that's funny
yeah
so so it can work but but so that was
the first
initiative and then now you've got a
whole new lol cartel
yeah i think eli wild card tells a great
name thanks yeah that's great too are
you saying what redman said that once or
something
yeah so it came from him um in my music
video for
my song sharon stoned so michael
rappaport and redmond were in the video
and they were
freestyling everything they were saying
like it was so funny everybody on set
was trying so hard to like keep their
mouth shut because they were being so
[ __ ] funny
and he goes he's like um you know like
they're supposed to be like
interrogating me and he's like you know
what
he goes i think i know who she works
with i think she with the lol cartel
everybody just started dying laughing
and like that
day we were like yo that should be like
that should be my thing like the lol
cartel
and i just went with it so shout out to
redman
what about your your outfits because
they're pretty iconic and like you
always look really good
and like as a dude i have whoa i thought
scott was about to say something that
was gonna get him into some serious
trouble right there
and we'll find out what he actually said
after i tell you
how much i love my fire pit from solo
stove
i keep it right in the cargo box on the
back of my rv
and i'm using this thing all the time
because who doesn't love to get around
the fire with your buddies and have a
good time
man i enjoy it plus it's got these cool
holes which allow
air to flow through which makes it
virtually smokeless
so you don't stink like smoke it burns
so
crazy bright and it's so much fun
and i want you to try it because again
who doesn't love being around the fire
so go to solostove.com
and use the promo code stevo and that's
going to get you ten dollars off at
checkout
why are you gonna do this because you
love being around the fire
and because you love stevo and you want
to support the wild ride podcast
so go to solostove.com and use the promo
code stevo
get 10 off any cool ass fire pit that
you want
and believe me you want one so head on
over
and let's see what scott really said
like as a dude i have
six different outfits that i just switch
and interchange and
like what's what's that audio is gonna
say something totally different
what's up with your outfits you know
they look really good and as a dude
i thought you were going to say like
something provocative something like
that no because i'm always so fascinated
with like how
like how do you come up with these
styles and like do you have a wardrobe
are these all at your house that you
pick and choose before the day
um well on ridiculousness like we film
six episodes a day so i gotta always
just have
like a massive selection of clothes to
pick from and
i pick out all my own outfits though
like it's all me like i put everything
together myself but i do have a stylist
that helps me shop for everything
i used to do a lot of the shopping but
then
the pandemic happened and i was just
like okay you can deal with
being in the mask all day this is the
first time
the first time doing a in-person podcast
in the van
where i realized that the the guest sits
under
my whole journey
socks and underwear and that's all my
clothes so do you take this van like for
traveling places oh my god i love it i
take it everywhere i think you would
rather live in here than anywhere else
that's funny
i i absolutely love it we'll drive this
to the like a hotel in oregon
you know we're doing shows and they got
us a nice hotel and steve's like no i'm
just gonna sleep in the parking lot in
this in this van
that's funny no my mom's kind of the
same she's like i just want a tiny house
i'm like no
you don't you are going to be miserable
after a week
yeah um so ridiculousness
is like how many years has that been
going now uh
i remember it was like 2012 the first
time i was on it
was it oh my god something like that no
it had to be i think it was like maybe
it's 2013 but it's absolutely yeah 2012
2013 that's
like when we started um so yeah i'm bad
at math how many years is that
nine like yeah yeah eight or nine and
i'll never forget the first time i was
on ridiculousness
like my instagram followers like went so
much higher yeah and then the second
time i was on ridiculousness they didn't
do [ __ ]
so probably the second time i feel like
now people don't even know the show's
still on
like so many people are like there's new
episodes i didn't even know it's on i
think they think it's just all reruns
you know so
my mom tivo's that i went to her house
the other day i'm like i love you
and tivo i do that too and it's like no
nobody has tivo
yeah it's not tivo um i
don't think that's i can't imagine
anybody not understanding that there's
new episodes of ridiculousness because
it's like you can't turn on mtv and see
anything but ridic i think the
ridiculousness
is like single-handedly keeping mtv
afloat
yeah well um can somebody ask them why
they didn't invite me to the mtv awards
because i was like mind [ __ ] i'm like
what and then some lady in the email
tried to use the pandemic as an excuse
i'm like
homegirl i've been filming all pandemic
and i follow 4 000 something people and
my whole damn timeline was at the
[ __ ] awards like what are you talking
about
crazy right yeah don't even invite me
i'm like what the [ __ ]
i've only ever been invited to any of
that [ __ ] like if there was
like one of our movies coming out like
yeah that [ __ ]
no john i remember johnny knoxville said
that he had to demand
two extra tickets for his like wife and
daughter or something
one time because they were like trying
to only give him one to and he's like
i'm not [ __ ] coming by myself like
give me a ticket for my family
and they finally gave it to him like
that's crazy because you're you're one
of three faces that is on their channel
more than anybody else right like
absolutely
i don't get it in the history of mtv is
that's why i'm using this opportunity to
say i do not
get it and i want to know who lost my
invite
you should make a rap about it i should
i should put in a song
where's my invite [ __ ] we want answers
so with with how many seasons of i mean
and
it's not like one season per year
there's like no like
it's like at this point i don't even
know how many a year like i feel like
every week i'm filming a new season
right i think i think you're in like
30-something seasons yeah
it's probably four years we're in our um
sorry baby we're in our uh
23rd season now but like just last month
it was the 22nd season so that's why i
was
i don't get how many we're doing like
you know it's just like it seems like
every week it's a new season
right in six episodes a day you're doing
yeah six episodes a day three days a
week
and then but it's not every week like we
film like two weeks and then we're off
for like
two and a half three weeks and then we
film two weeks then we're off two and a
half three weeks so how long does a six
six episodes take to making a day like
eight hours
ten hours no dude they knock it out so
[ __ ] fast
like these episodes the episode is 22
minutes
on tv like shooting it from start to
finish
maybe 30 minutes right maybe maybe four
no even our producer matt he was like
sometimes you guys go too fast and like
i'm like yo i need more
like there's not enough to even you know
make the show
have you gone to uh rob's uh
hypno no dude dr pratt okay
so i got hypnotized on an episode of
fantasy factory but i'm just
i admitted it recently on ridiculousness
i was like i was just kind of faking for
tv
i didn't want to make the guy feel bad
like i was like let me just go along
with this
like was it uh dr pratt
i don't i don't know and maybe it's the
old guy he's the old guy right from san
diego because rob
said like the reason for success and
going like exponential was because he
met up with dr pratt but i don't know
that's what they so i think it was him
because
that's what they tried to do to me
they're like we're gonna hypnotize you
to be funnier
are you saying it didn't work i don't
think i mean i
you're pretty funny were you not funny
before i feel like i've always been
funny
i was like maybe i got like more opened
up after but that's just from like being
like more experienced
in front of the camera now you know like
i don't think it was him
yeah yeah um so it's 23 seasons of
ridiculousness
yep like and they've got
they've got to be like paying you more
and more as you go right they want to
keep you doing it you got
like your contract that goes up bringing
up all the greatest questions right now
can i get a paper towel real quick my
hands are sweaty sorry
i get the sweaty hands it's a white one
though i hope you're okay with that
that's
totally fine you're gonna be able to see
like what's going on on the white paper
top
maybe one more i know it's like it seems
like you're struggling there sorry
um thanks one for each hand
yeah um so yeah i mean i feel like i
should be getting a lot of raises but uh
you know
we'll see what happens soon yeah yeah
the numbers in that that nikki swift
video were like really weird and random
they were like
and she got like a hundred and some like
thousand and thirty one dollars but they
had no
like context for like the frames of time
i don't know where they get any of this
info i saw one one time that um
sterling supposedly makes 130 grand per
episode and i was like if that's
the case i might go jump off a bridge
right now and kill myself
not to make jokes about that but um so
i don't know where they get this info
because i don't think she's making
anything like that
you'd have to be like jersey shore like
in their heyday
yeah have you ever both you guys ever
googled your net worth and it's been
accurate
like you know that has everything net
worth like how do you
think i
actually one time google next i'm like
what's my network like let's see if
there
and then i saw what it was and i'm like
i feel like i might have more money than
that i don't know
i remember uh dude i mean that's weird
how how would they know
i only heard about this like right after
jackass 3d came out they had an episode
of tosh.0 and tosh point
daniel tosh he says uh you know
the whole bit was you can google uh
someone's like
like a net worth he says so we googled
the jackass guys
this is on the show i heard about he
says johnny knoxville is a reported net
worth like
80 million or something crazy then they
say bam marchers
net worth 45 million and then stevo 2.5
two more my friend here's the thing when
when that
went down like my buddy told me that
and i was like [ __ ] out they know
they know that they got they know but uh
how do they know
but that but uh i mean that is i mean
they just
guess what they got me
they got me but that's my question is
theirs really that high
like do they really have that much money
yeah is knoxville's 80 million
i mean that's what that toy was reported
i don't know i feel like that's like
i can i can get money
i can guarantee you that i'm not going
to guarantee anything
right um but uh yeah it's it's pretty
crazy and i think that in general those
network things are
just wildly [ __ ] wrong yeah i think
they just like
they look up a couple things that you
might own like your house your car
they they look up a couple purses on
your instagram like oh
she's got a chain okay here we go it's
like how else do they know
and i've been 2.2.5 ever since you know
it doesn't increase or go down at all
yeah 2.5 ever since
you know and and i fell on some rough
times man really
what about like wikipedia is that
accurate um
wikipedia had a lot of like a wrong [ __ ]
on there they still say i was married
twice on there my sister's been like
trying to i've never been married
my sister's been trying her ass off
she's like him
because it drives her [ __ ] nuts my
sister's protective and she's
i'm her little brother that's cool she's
going against the system
but uh so so you feel that the
raise is in order for ridiculousness i
agree i think i
love you for bringing this up i hope rob
watches this
i uh rob's responsible for your raise
right
for sure well tell them pratt told you
that you're gonna get a raise pretty
soon you're here and you're hypnotherapy
i think it's interesting that that would
be rob's call but i guess it makes sense
because it's it's his production company
that makes the show
so right it's like i mean he's fully in
charge it's his show it's you know
all right how much how much more do you
want an episode or is it a year or
an episode or i don't know i don't want
to get into all this yeah we don't have
to we don't need to get into
first of all let me just put it out
there i'm so grateful to be on the show
to be in this situation like the first
day back from the pandemic i literally
like had a moment where i was like
well they also made her call time
earlier so i was like half asleep
and at first i was like pissed off
because i like kicked my shin that
morning leaving in the dark i'm like
[ __ ] this earlier call time like all
pissed and then i'm like driving to work
like
okay like you're driving a tv show in
its
20th season during a pandemic when
people don't have jobs
like and i just like had this moment of
being so grateful
and like i don't know i can't explain it
like i was like
wow like i've never been more like more
grateful
in my life than just recently like i
kind of like
especially as an artist like being on
ridiculousness at first i felt like it
was holding me back a little bit with my
music and stuff and
i've always been grateful to be there
but maybe resented a little bit like the
fact that i'm on a show that like
doesn't i don't get to showcase my music
and people just think i like all i do is
laugh
all day um so yeah so it took
after being in the pandemic and and then
the new earlier call time somehow led to
it but i'm like
more grateful than ever um i do think
that i could have a little raise though
yeah especially because i have to show
up the earliest like i'm the girl i have
to show up two and a half hours early to
get ready
and it's a lot of um i don't even think
like how long it takes to get ready is
the the thing it's just like you can't
you are ridiculous the three of you guys
there's three people on it like there's
uh
you know it's like you guys it's a
wildly successful show and you guys
should all share and
and the profits for sure um
so back to your music the uh like do you
get
separate checks from like spotify and
then another one from like
like what are other streaming things
pandora apple tv like pandora
spotify like yeah pandora pays you too
they would but
they would have to right yeah the um the
oh hello
the app you make the best money off of
is title
oh app yeah you make the most money off
them which is great
um but they don't i so i'm actually
speaking of jay-z i'm with
eq distribution so i have a distribution
label but i like i fund everything
myself so
they put it out for me like help me get
on some of the playlists and stuff
um so they're the ones who send me the
money so i don't know exactly how
like it comes in like that but um but
yeah
no like it's cool i made more most of my
money through music from my gigs though
oh okay good so so we've got
for our revenue streams we've got the
the ticket sales from your live shows
yep we've got the
the ridiculousness the regular gig
yep and then we've got the the streaming
like the music sales yeah on the music
sales
how does like actual purchases of the
album on itunes stack up against the
streaming
for revenue for you um
not not as not as much i mean first of
all people
don't download music the way they used
to um
it's really weird ever since they like
remember when they changed it to where
like you had to download the songs like
hear them on the plane and stuff like i
think ever since then
not really anybody downloads the music
like you got to be like a super fan
or you know somebody that's constantly
like
needing your phone in airplane mode like
that's why you're like oh let me
download every single one
but for the most part everybody just
streams so streaming's where the money's
coming that's spotify
yeah streaming is where it's at and the
being on the playlists is what really
helps you like i'm still trying to get
on some of these big key playlists
and i think once i get on those ones
like that's when it's going to all start
that's like if you're like i want to
listen to what j.lo's listening to
like i want to be on her plane i feel
like no remember like in the tesla like
how it's like 90s music like is that
that's what it is caviar yeah and it's
funny that you mentioned the 90s music
one too because so
there's so many playlists on spotify and
like every now and then
um like i was on the 90s playlist and i
discovered a new song by some new arm
like this is not a 90 song this is
brand new dropped like a month ago and
discovered them so
so these playlisting things work really
random i don't know who's in control of
them but like
it's just like getting on any playlists
that have like
even a few thousand listeners it helps
because
you know like people people are always
looking for like i'll be like in the
love song mood or something right and
i'm like love songs and then there's
like five love song playlists and like
when you get on these playlists that's
just that's where it's at
really okay yeah cause you just yeah and
then what kind of money is it when
you know people put out their music
video on youtube like
by themselves like music on youtube gets
like hundreds
of billion like millions of views like
who gets that money
uh so for my youtube i'm with live
nation
um there's all these different little
things like as an independent artist or
influencer there are so many different
ways to make money
and youtube is uh live nation's really
great was like getting your money like
they
you know because they put like the ads
and that stuff so you make money through
ads at the beginning of the music video
animation for youtube i've never heard
of it but couldn't you had like start
your own youtube channel which you
probably already have and put your own
music video on there
yeah but um i don't know like i i don't
know how i don't know exactly how it
works
just having people like live nation or a
company like that that does it for you
like you end up making
more money that way okay it's like being
with the network i guess unless you know
it's like
as like these huge mega youtube like
unless you're at their level like
you know that but i'm trying to get
there i think you're already there
i mean you're kind of killing it i
thanks i mean it's so i'm a virgo
like so we're perfectionists i feel like
people will be like
dude you sound insane like i i have a
tendency to talk about myself like i
literally am still like working at my
nine to five like
taking the bus they're like bro you're
on tv internationally
what's wrong with you and i'm just like
i know it's just me like i haven't had a
hit single yet so in my head
i'm not like i don't know i'm not like i
don't know
and i grew up here in l.a like all my
friends from [ __ ] high school are
like
like around the corner you know what i
mean like danielle like we've been
kicking it since high school days like
really
yeah you know so it's like especially
growing up here being from here being
around all the same people you kind of
like
and la so like nobody acts like you're
anything so like i get like
this like it's when i leave the state
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm famous
like people know who i am that's right
yeah
when did you first realize you're famous
like in another state like when people
came up to you you're like oh [ __ ] this
is wrong
i mean way back in the fantasy factory
days right i mean that was
like a huge show on mtv back then and
that was when mtv was way bigger
when i made my twitter as though when i
really like when i realized it cause i
had a myspace and a facebook fan page
when i started fantasy factory
and i saw that they were kind of like
you know buzzing but i already kind of
had a buzz
on myspace and i already had a little
bit of a buzz on facebook on my own
without tv
and then um i remember coming to work
everyone's talking about twitter
and shane our producer was like you
should make a twitter and i was like
dude i can't even keep up with the
myspace and the facebook and he's like i
promise you like this is gonna be like
he's like you don't have to follow the
or like add the people back i was like i
don't have to add them back
sign me up like i'm like this sounds
easy
and so then in like two or three days i
had like
like 30 000 followers and i was like 30
000 people care to like fall like
without me having to add them back you
know and so then um and then the twitter
just started going crazy
and and how many do you have on twitter
now
that that kind of slowed down once
instagram came out so i have like
almost 900 000 on twitter i kind of
slowed down once instagram came out then
i went hard with instagram and that's
where my following
like my twitter just stopped like uh
it stopped yeah i even started to lose
followers on twitter i was like
i haven't even posted anything like what
are you guys offended by like
we were so weird i lose so many
followers on a daily basis
oh yeah i mean i gained a lot too but
like you know that that's by design i
think that that's like bots doing their
thing that's not actually people
unfollowing that's like some some weird
bot [ __ ] they unfollow and then follow
again for there's something to it
it broke my heart too like all the
instagram insights like how are people
with so many like
well does that still happen where all of
a sudden like one day you'll lose like
300 000 followers and you're like what
the [ __ ] they're not that many
i think on my instagram insights i saw
how many unfollows there are and i was
like
wait a second like so i googled like why
are so many [ __ ] people unfollowing
me
and then i found out it's like some bot
[ __ ] uh-huh yeah no i was i was kind of
offended
so i was trying to figure it out i'm
like what is it that i'm posting that
people are like so mad about like
at one of the things though that i do
think makes people actually unfollow
and it's girls uh when you post sexy
pictures girls tend to hate on that like
oh yeah
it's weird and it's like well it's just
jealousy like uh
i mean they should i feel like they
should be inspired like i follow a bunch
of like hot girls that like work out all
the time and i'm like
i like following [ __ ] like that because
i'm like oh [ __ ] like this girl's got an
eight pack
time to work out again like you know
like so that type of stuff motivates me
like i don't get why people
i wouldn't like to follow that yeah i'm
pretty sure that you're gonna do just
fine posting sexy photos
like i think in the long run that's
gonna benefit you more than it's
well that's that's why i'm getting into
my my next business thing i want to do
is uh starting a whole full like
beachwear brand
and i realized that because like my
bikini pictures do so
anytime i post on the beach jumping in a
pool ocean
a booty in a bikini it's does great
great numbers and see i even get guys
like that's a nice bikini
why do you care you know so like i'm
like i want to start a beach
brand so i can just start like [ __ ]
vacationing and likes
and you know selling [ __ ] at the same
time and because uh
because just on tmz like this week or
last week kylie jenner though
she's going of course kylie jenner's
getting into the beach wear
beach swimming all that [ __ ]
business like a couple like 10 years ago
no chance now
no i think you'll do i got really
obsessed with like the terry cloth
lifestyle like i wanted to have clothes
made out of terry cloth
like everything that i did like made it
i had i asked for a suit made
out of cherry cloth it'd just be like
the beach lifestyle i love
terry sarah calls me well my hands get
sweaty so i love
oh my gosh she's towels your brother
like you i have the worst sweaty hands
yeah that's right because
it's your brother too have you looked
into it because i'm getting surgery
i so i just got like i'm not a
i'm not a medication type person like i
just got this medication to try i tried
it yesterday and it made me freezing i
was like
now i'm shivering and i'm like i don't
want to [ __ ] feel cold either like
but your hands aren't sweaty
i looked into having the surgery to get
like my sweat gland removed from my
armpit but then i didn't want to start
sweating somewhere else
i know that's it one of those hole in a
boat like
no one of the side of it i remember it
said it's a possible sweat in the back
of your
uh thighs yeah and you're just dripping
sweat because it has to go somewhere
yeah i'm like i'd rather sweat from like
normal places
than yeah i just started yeah exactly
but i get sweaty hands and sweaty feet
and so like
even sandals that have that like kind of
terry cloth material like i love that
for sure i used to like you know and
like scott and i go to these gatherings
right where like after the gathering
everybody like holds hands and says a
prayer
and scott like gets really really like
dude thinks i'm like
i got eight years sober people think i'm
like detoxing off coke
because i've been dripping sweating oh
like even on the mike tyson podcast she
was like what's up
and and i shook hands and you just see
him going like this
right after and i can't stop thinking
about it like
it's like it's like yeah it's really
annoying everybody everybody holds hands
and
feels god's hand on your back yeah i
know i like i don't
it drives me crazy like i don't even
like to hold him like
in a relationship they're like my
ex-boyfriend who like
he still like probably texted me an hour
ago and
he like is won't get over me but um
he broke up with you because your sweaty
hands like hold my hand i'm like i don't
want to my hands when he's like i don't
care and i'm like i
do like it's like i don't like the
feeling like holding your hand while my
hands like sweaty it's like
it's weird you know yes you have like
lotion you put lotion on your body like
it's just a weird like slime i don't put
lotion on
my hands or feet and then i actually
feel like i'm like great now my hands
start to look like they're 80 because i
never put lotion on them
so they're like starting to look cold
yeah so like what what i do now like
before i go to bed is i'll like put
lotion on the outside and like
go like that really your feet sweat too
because mine dripped yeah my feet my
hands
went so bad and like i told um no
i told my doctor i was like you
understand i was like i
i get excited to wear sandals in the
winter like i do
literally like in the winter i get more
like into sandals or
heels and then in the summer i'm like i
was like why are you always in sneakers
i'm like
because i don't feel like slipping
everywhere all day like
i want to just be able to walk you know
do you think that
two people who know each other
have super sweaty hands would
like to be okay holding hands they just
put each other's hands in their pockets
like i'll put it in her pocket she'll
put it in my pocket
we have sweaty hands
yeah like we're like i used to be stoked
like at a bar like playing pool because
they used to have the powder and i'm
like
just constantly putting powder all over
my hand
like that like i get like i've never
seen that episode of friends where he
where he had this the the pants and then
they were leather and they and they were
sticking to him and so i forgot which it
was ross and one of those like
put some powder and then he puts the
powder like to try and stop like from
sweating and like not being able to
and then he's like it's turning into
paste yeah exactly
exactly dude people don't understand the
struggle of sweaty hands
yeah it is bad i wonder why i said that
your brother your brother has sweaty
hands too though we both have sweaty
hands so you said you've been sober
though and you still have sweaty hands
yeah okay because i thought for a while
i was like it's gotten a little better
but
i'm just like like i have the softest
man hands
and it's like because my hands sweat so
much and so it's like
you know some girls find like rough
hands you know sexy on a man because
it's like wow this guy's like
doing construction i have like the
softest hands
ever known to man and like it's kind of
you know i'm pretty sure that most girls
don't
find a guy doing construction sexy
no i mean like you know you can like
build [ __ ] and like dude
right right and it's like they're just
like callous tanned like hi i'm a man
nice to meet you
right your hand just slips right outside
i've never like like i've never been
like oh like this is a rough hand like
he
he must be like you know but i have
noticed the other way like he has really
soft hair oh my god
that's crazy though because i thought um
i do notice that when i don't drink i
sweat way less yeah and then um the
weird thing is like i've i mean i've
been smoking
and grew up in l.a i've been smoking
weed since i was like 12. and
you have weed businesses too yes yeah
yeah well i
i don't want to talk about that yet but
yeah yeah okay um
but uh but yeah i thought that sometimes
too like i need to smoke because
sometimes i'll be like like hot water
and then i smoke and then i completely
stop and i'm like
is this a problem that developed from
like smoking weed or something
you know no it's probably just like an
anxiety issue yeah
but you know i i notice it's dropped
80 percent you know but i used to be
[ __ ]
it dropped 80 since when since getting
getting set
he's like you used to be he's like used
to be sweatier
like it it was really bad we're like
like i would just like give knuckles
like in the 90s before knuckles were
like you know pre-pandemic it's like
people are like oh what's up and they're
like damn dude like
what's up bro it's a wet nook it's a wet
nut
yeah dude that's my rap name wet nut wet
you like hug people they're like
drowning
the weed business is is coming yeah yeah
i'm gonna really like expand on that
too do you ever get like uh brand
integration deals for like social media
posts
yeah a ton ton i never get [ __ ]
get them from well do people know that
you're fully sober now and all that
stuff yeah
probably this guy's insane we're not
giving him anything like we mean
companies
over 13 years that's crazy right but see
that's what i'm saying those because
like
like jackass reruns they're living on
and like you know people are seeing all
this crazy [ __ ] you've done that well i
still do crazy [ __ ] you sorry i jumped
into the tv today yeah yeah
but like i feel like when we they're not
thinking somebody's sober's doing that
right like weed companies have so much
money they need to give it away to
market like
they're not you know what i mean well
i'm not promoting weeds yeah that's what
that's
do do you have a company like collab or
something that
that uh does your your uh
brand gets your deals for you um no
everything's like real separate like do
you have an agent against that
yeah i just got new agents yep okay i
got to figure out how to get some of
this [ __ ] social media post money
yeah the social media post money is good
because that's where like
they know nobody's watching commercials
anymore and like like
that like these companies don't even
want to do your conventional advertising
they'd rather just pay influencers
yeah you know we're gonna go wheel of
fortune commercials like
you know instagram it's like everybody's
looking at their instagram
yeah during the commercials so are you
getting more from the social media posts
than ridiculousness definitely not
ridiculousness is my bread and butter
that's probably why i haven't complained
about a race
okay i'm like i'll just take it give me
whatever
all right yeah so so the number one
revenue stream is ridiculousness yes
um but i mean i i'm making great money
off of
my my music and gigs and off my merch
i do make good money off everything else
but definitely i mean
look how many episodes we're doing like
yeah right i get good nonstop
and then uh social media posts versus
the
music streaming hmm that's that's a
tough one once a month it might
bounce back and forth i would say i'm
well because i i think of like the
youtube
money too which i do really good monthly
with youtube also
how often are you posting videos on
youtube uh like just today i posted um
a workout video with my friend margie
which is hilarious you guys should watch
it
she's a plus-sized girl i'm a small girl
so the goal was to show like you know
big girls and
small girls can do the same exact
workouts she definitely struggled a
little more with some of them
but uh but yeah like i do workout videos
i'm posting like
lots of lifestyle like the vlog type
[ __ ] like especially when i go out for
my shows we're filming from the second
either the second i i'm taking off from
here the second i land depending on
where the video guy is
but like all the lifestyle vlogs [ __ ] i
have all my music videos
then i got a behind the scenes for every
music video
um who's editing your videos uh
my music videos i will sit there and
edit every single one with whoever the
hell is doing it i'm like i'm sitting
there and editing with you
just because like you know
editing a girl video is just different
you got to find the sexiest shots
that's what it's all about it's finding
every shot where i look skinny how's the
booty look you know what i mean
so sometimes like people editing don't
look at that stuff they're looking at
like
overall like the cinematic like how like
the sunset and it's like dude i look
[ __ ] there why are we using that
shot you know
so you need scott to edit your videos
you're like making sure your hands don't
glisten in the right light
exactly little [ __ ] like that you know
so all of
all my music videos i help edit um but
like the regular vlog stuff like uh yeah
i have like video guys i work with
um like my main go to guys actually so
funny my one video guy pat who's from
illinois
i need to introduce everybody tells him
he looks like stevo oh cool
i gotta show you a picture and where do
they work at um he he's based in
illinois but like he'll come out here
all the time like he'll be here next
week
oh okay i actually should just like walk
up here and just introduce you
he no i'm not joking everybody's like
dude you know who you look like he's
like stevo
yeah for sure it's pretty funny you guys
can be brothers right
for the vlog yeah i mean dude like we're
cranking out like we need more help to
edit
videos now oh yeah i i'll refer you my
boy ghost
who's like my main guy he lives in
palmdale but
he he's out in la like weekly okay
he's really good i'll send him your way
all right
quick question what what did you buy
with your first major paycheck
coming from nothing to getting a fat
paycheck what's the first thing you buy
probably what was my first like big
paycheck uh
probably my house oh really i wasn't
getting like as big as like
lump sums until like we started doing
way more episodes so
that's cool how long have you been in
the house uh not that long right
it's crazy how time flies so the
pandemic that's a year then the year
before that
it's like three years i remember when
they like it was like one house and it
was like real
pretty rickety and then they just like
practically tore the [ __ ] thing down
and
rebuilt it yep was that you like uh
rebuilding it no i didn't do that the
people who who i bought it
from did that but i i did a lot more too
like i built the pool there was no pool
there before like i redid the whole
backyard the landscaping
the landscape dude you have like the
little levels yeah
and and we were driving up me and my
girl and she like
like when she yelled out like uh the car
she was like hey like i love what you're
doing
like uh and got the jude's card and i
think he [ __ ] did something
in our backyard that's my gardener i
think really
yeah that's got to be him he's always
there
uncle lou yeah i forget how to ask my
girl
yeah no we we went in on the landscaping
they came up to us
it's so funny the fire department or
something like sent us a thing
saying that we were gonna get fined
because it was too much brush and i'm
like
that's the hill like i moved into the
hills like
so i had to just landscape the whole
hill and get it nice because they were
gonna like
yeah they kept bugging us about it yeah
i have a question about something i
watched your nardwar interview
uh-huh and you guys asked well first of
all did you
because you're like where'd you learn
all this stuff did you ever find out
like did anyone ever tell you like oh
like i talked to nard where i
i fed him all that i'm like i think his
family's like the cia or some [ __ ]
because he the way he knows things like
i was not even as popular back then like
like a lot of the facts he knew i'm like
i don't know where he got it
like it was weird well and then one of
the things he brought up was that like
jay-z touched your shoulder when you're
like 10. and you guys kind of just
brushed through it like what's the story
there how does jay-z touch your shoulder
when you're ten
it's the funniest story um so my dad
lived in new york
uh when i was growing up so i'd always
go out there to visit him
and my dad was a dj and this is the
funniest thing so he'd always sleep in
really late because he worked at night
but my dad's wake-up call would be
taking me to trl
i'm like that's almost three trl's about
to start taking me to tears so he always
it was like a daily thing he's like okay
we're going to trl again
and so like i'd wake up my dad i'm like
it's almost three come on come on we
gotta go
and one day we go to trl and jay-z's
there and
it was like big pimpin was like i think
out at the time and he's like
you know he's a big rapper i knew who he
was like as a kid like i was like oh
it's jay-z
and so i go to the door where you enter
to go in the building and the security
guy's just not looking
and i was like one of those i've always
been like that like i'm like a like i'm
gonna make it happen
you know what i mean like like i'm gonna
end up backstage like i always just
figure it out
and so i saw the the security guard
turned his head and i'm just like [ __ ]
it and i just ran
and my dad's like what are you doing and
he comes after me and the security like
isn't paying attention we somehow get
past the security and i'm at the top of
the escalator in the building where
uh like trl used to be and jay-z is
walking out with like his whole
entourage and i'm like oh
oh my god that's jay-z and i'd like turn
and like freeze up
and jay-z must've saw from a distance
he's like who's this little girl like
all nervous you know how old were you
i was like ten nine or ten and
he comes up because he probably saw that
i was like nervous because i literally
was like looking at him and then like
turned around like oh [ __ ] i'm not
supposed to be here you know like i'm
like trying to hide
and jay-z came up and he was like hi
what's your name
and um and my first name is chelsea i'm
like chelsea like all like nervous like
shaking
and he's like you don't got to be scared
to say hi and he's like if you want to
say hi to somebody you go right up to
them and say hi and he like gave me this
little life lesson and i was like
okay shook his hand my dad had a camera
and my dad like froze didn't take a
picture or anything
and it was just like this moment that
like i've always been like
dude i was like i feel like jay-z like
blessed me like she will be a rapper
like when he touched my shoulder you
know i'm like i wish i could meet him
and tell him that story
like so bad that's ironically we're
talking about this i just did
uh michelle williams from destiny's
child podcast this morning
oh wow yeah and so i told her i was like
it's so great like
that's funny we're bringing this up now
so i haven't worked my way to
beyonce and jay-z yet but you know i'm
getting there
you got title yeah no even michelle
williams today told me
uh she listened to my album and she said
you got vocals and i'm like somebody
from destiny's child is telling me i got
vocals like
i literally got chills like when she
told me so yeah crazy so did you ever
figure out how he knew that in hardware
uh i think i might have maybe like
talked about it in a
another like low end like i don't some
little random interview or something
i don't know where he heard it so weird
because it i looked it up after that and
i was like i don't even know where i
said this you know what i mean like and
i don't know how he found out all the
info about like
my dad because that wasn't even online
yet
it was interesting that's weird man i
want a nardwar interview
oh my god he's like it's it it's so cool
like he just he brings you these little
gifts and like knows so much about your
life when he gave you the
the gifts did he ask for any of them
back no okay
you get to keep them that's good yeah
nice
um okay so now ask your other question
what's my other question
when she's on tour what's on her rider
oh yeah yeah
thank you you like that question i
[ __ ] love that okay so now
you're on tour what's on your writer
um so this is so funny because
i just i go to get my like i got my
first gig after the pandemic
and my girl sent me who works with me
she's like okay just approving like
ryder's still the same and i was like
what the [ __ ]
there's no white claw on there right
we haven't been drinking since seltzer's
came out so like oh [ __ ]
even my buddies are drinking salts from
like you what are you doing
bud light in there poopies showed up at
the [ __ ]
warehouse with a seltzer 12 pack of
seltzers
and he was all already [ __ ] hammered
they're so good
the next day they're [ __ ] they're all
stinking up the trash can
seltzer i'm like i'm like poopies i
really don't need you drunk at our
warehouse
like [ __ ] so so white claw is on
there
so white claw's on there now i could not
believe it i was like it's been that
long since i've had a show
like i feel like i've been drinking
white clothes my whole life you know
that's funny yeah so white claws on
there
vodka that's okay that answers my
questions it says white claw like some
like
like bottom shell [ __ ] like low grade
no why didn't these no white claws good
yeah so it's not like boons
or something like it's not like lemonade
or anything like that
i am curious of what the alcohol is
we're drinking it's vodka no
is it i don't know so it's just vodka in
a can now
i don't even know what the alcohol is
that's the question that we all are
trying to figure out i think
cheetos is some i think celtics is like
zema or something right
but uh right tito's is shitty but it's
good because it's gluten free
so it's like real skinny vodka it's like
skinny yeah
it's the best it's like that's how you
stay skinny drinking is tito's
all right i think the last i'm like over
here like preaching like how to stay
how does they fit while eating alcohol
yeah you just ride that drunk
i love how steve's reference is zema
like uh
that's a dated alcohol reference i used
to drink zima
uh because i could i was able to pound
zimas when i had like
ruthless hangovers mm-hmm like it was
just
i think the bottle was really cool
that's all i remember of zlatan was
a sweet like was there sugar in it i i
don't know it was just like the biggest
like most embarrassing [ __ ] drink it's
like dude why don't you drink a zima
yeah
and you just chain smoke in in zima's
yeah you're like a like a 60 year old
housewife that's brunch for stuff
so so what else is on the right are
tito's white cloth uh
perrier sparkling water regular water
i always have a veggie tray and i eat it
every time i'm always wasted like
where's the veggie tray
and then hummus hummus and veggies so i
like to try to stay like
healthy while i know i'm drinking a lot
of calories how long are you on stage
for
it depends club gigs are usually shorter
like 15 minutes
oh wow yeah 30 minutes but um
yeah it depends like if it's more of
like a venue show then it's usually a
full set like 45 minutes to an hour
but the club gigs are more like smaller
stage likes
you know they just want a quick set a
couple songs dude
what's gonna happen when your rap career
takes off and you have a comedy show
or a or like a rap gig what do you know
what do you do
i'm gonna do i'm gonna always do both
and that has been a struggle with
ridiculousness that's also why i like i
did like resent it a little because i've
missed a lot of things because of it i
missed a van's warp tour i missed
south by southwest performances a
freaking festival in maui which like who
doesn't want to perform at a festival in
maui like
that one sucked i've like missed so many
different
performances and things for my music
because of it but
my contract you know it has first
priority like obviously a huge
production doesn't work around just
one person's schedule so yeah um i feel
like you can
after this you can do whatever you want
to do and like
put on your own shows yeah for sure i'm
working on my own
tv shows yeah good what my my one i'm
working on now like i'm gonna move to
miami part time
it's gonna be like west coast takes east
coast okay cause it's just like
i've been here my whole life like yeah
i'm chanel west coast that's my brand
but like
i just love miami i feel like i was
meant to be there first of all i don't
need makeup there
it's just like you glow like it's just i
feel like i look dry here or something
like i don't know like i just love miami
like
you can let your hands sweat in miami
that's another thing too
i've noticed i don't know if it's
because it's humid or something like
maybe because it's so dry here that like
maybe the body's like
it's dry it's because the rest the rest
of your body's sweating in miami so like
it's like taking over the load for your
hands
i don't even get a sweaty there that's
what i noticed and i'm like what the
[ __ ] it's so humid but i'm not
sweating as bad here um
yeah like there's just so many things i
love about the water it's perfect it's
always warm
even when it's overcast and rainy it's
warm like
i just like the warm nice
i don't know tropical vibes and so this
would be like a reality show
yeah like lifestyle reality show yep
sweetie is it
is it in the works yeah i'm literally
gonna just move there and just film
everything
and it's so funny because it's gonna be
like it's like my other side of me like
here like my house is like modern i have
my suv like there my house is gonna be
like
all like boho beach vibes i'm gonna have
like maybe like
you know like a little convertible like
i'm gonna be full beach like miami like
yeah it's gonna be fun i don't know like
what you talking about puppy
i'm gonna start speaking with a spanish
accent tony montana like the female
version
yeah no like i love miami my friends
were like teasing me like dude you need
to get 305 tatted on you
nice i like la number one two miami i
think is my my family's in south florida
i love it like
literally like i mean they're still in
south beach it's still like mad
expensive
front for 305 condo right you're like
what right outside of the [ __ ]
downtown south beach you get a house for
600 000 and you're still 20 minutes from
crystal blue water like it's so much
nicer here in hollywood it takes a
[ __ ]
hour and a half just to get to the beach
yeah or you can buy one bedroom one bath
in burbank for
does that make any 9.80 dude yeah well
it's where people want to be so uh
we're not ready to promote the the the
weed business
not yet but we are ready to promote lol
cartel yes
lol cartel i got all new designs i'm
dropping
like i'm literally after this the guys
are bringing the samples to my house
cool because the whole new line is about
to drop in zoomies and on my website
and and so we're promoting your website
big time yes
i am chanellewestcoast.com
chanelwestcoast.com and that's where you
get all the merch
uh yes you get every everything there my
music ever
everything me is on my website chanel
west coast
i am chanel west coast some weirdos in
the west coast and he's in like some
random like
serbia he's literally in the country
like it's no it's like one it's like
it's not kazakhstan it's like it's one
of
them it's so annoying it's crazy okay so
i am chanel westcoast.com yep
and uh your instagram chanel west coast
facebook channel west coast youtube
chanel west coast
everything chanel west coast cwc yep
i love that your agents are like cwc
will be right with you i'm like i love
that
and is there anything else we want to
promote uh
really my music is the main thing i want
to promote my album america's american
sweetheart
yeah it's a lot of people slept on it
but there's 19 songs on there
you know there's some love songs party
songs if you feel like fighting there's
a
fight song with too short what what
other
features do you have uh two shorts on
there dreezy
um to my two girls anaya
anaya love note salma slims soma slims
is she's
she's really blowing up right now so
zanaya they're both blowing up
and my girl porcelain black the song
porcelain's on is sick
it's like very different like poor it's
very like
it's it's hardcore rap but like she's
like [ __ ] like kind of almost like
metal screaming like on the on the hook
definitely a moshing song like
my album is like you can get a little
taste of everything on there right
and especially with a platform as big as
yours can you just spread the word about
not hating on sweaty hand people
yeah most importantly well how also you
got
this fight you gotta um you'll get just
shout out bounty because like i
literally like said like i was like yeah
i gotta have my bounty on decks i'm
always sweating and i get a [ __ ]
whole gift package from bounty but did
they make it black
no oh that's [ __ ]
that would be a good idea to reach out
to bounty like hey we should do a collab
black paper towel
for sure black bounty but yeah no people
need to stop hating on the sweaty hands
thank you finally someone says it it's
so weird though because when my hands
are dry
and i touch a sweaty hand i'm like and
i'm like [ __ ] that's you
relax you know like so i get it you know
people like they can get grossed out i
guess
but you know we're all human good
yeah way to speak up for the little
people
when do you uh when do you go take more
ridiculous shows tomorrow
like do you have a favorite guest who's
been on ridiculousness
i def i always say i mean snoop was one
of my fav
first of all snoop's the only person in
history we've waited for
okay like no but you know we're very
fast paced rob is all about like make
sure they're on time
if the person's like running like late
he'll be like reschedule him like he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
and uh snoop was dude the whole
we were filming next to like a kid's tv
show like the next
set was a literal like kids show and
like he's the whole set
smelled like oh geez like they literally
the people from the other show were like
hey like
we need and they're like dude we're like
snoops here what do you want us to do
yeah how late was he um he was
i don't know how late i can't say for
when i did his show
it got pushed back like four hours
i'm dead serious i was just partying at
the place like chilling with french
montana
getting high as hell like for his show
it was like four hours
wait um but yeah he was like an hour or
something late which is like
unreal like nobody's ever that late for
our show yeah i can't imagine smoking
weed getting blazed as [ __ ] and then
going on national television i'd just be
like
that was the only time i've ever been
that high filming too i feel like people
think i'm high 24 7 because i get small
eyes when i laugh
but i'm sober all the time filming and
that
one if you watch like i'm literally like
you can't even see my eyes the whole
episode
post malone was a uh because post had to
come twice because the first time he
came
our show went on strike oh wow and so
post thought he was getting punked or
something
so that situation was funny we're
outside like just chilling smoking and
and they come and they're like so um the
whole crew left
and post is like what what what's going
on and he's like oh my beauties
right now he's the coolest dude how nice
is he dude he's so nice
if you guys have his number can you hook
me up i'm like trying so hard to like
get in contact with him like i need to
do a song with him so bad
dude everybody we just had said that
other
every single person that you bring him
up to oh my god i have to do
he's the most in demand dude ever in the
world and i'm sure once people get at
him he's like yeah of course but like
you know
no but i know for a fact that post bucks
with me like so my friend was friends
with him before he was famous
and my friend told me a story he goes
dude post
was in his tiny whities and this is yo
i don't know posted this for sure true
but this is what i was told
he said i watched post chill in his tiny
whities and just sit on youtube on his
laptop watching your videos for an
hour and a half straight just like
enamored by you
and i'm like are you kidding me i was
like why didn't you ever tell me this
sooner like he's like dude he's like i
i've never had the chance to tell you
but like he's like yeah post is a fan
and i'm like
that's so tight like because he wasn't
even famous then yet he was just like
you know
just all right boy just just a boy in
tidyway
that's great let's see if we can we can
figure it out
that sounds good yeah my new album's
definitely like um that's also why i
want to work with him so my new album
i'm working on is going way more like
pop rock direction
so like i've had a few people be like yo
this is like like a female post malone
vibe
so i really want to get him on like one
of my songs for for sure on his next
album i feel like mgk's pop rock too
properly he went from rap to to like
blink 182
sound kind of all right i want to get
back on ridiculousness too
yeah you got to come i'll ask shauna so
you've been on there
twice right twice yeah that was just
nothing like you had probably had people
on their side brendan
has the record is like i was like he's
i'm like he's here again
does he just like live next door like
they're like just come over
snoop's late again i think we just have
very similar fan bases
and that's why they like having him so
much because like the people who listen
to his podcast
and and watch our show are apparently
like exactly the same or something
crossover right okay cool all right well
we will uh look forward to that we'll
[ __ ] get post malone
obviously if i can find out if that's
true yeah find out
chanel heard the story that you were
literally in your tidy
i don't know if that's the way to break
it
i don't know if that's the way to bring
it up but but yeah so it's good so
everyone get over to i am chanelle
westcoast.com
american sweetheart america america
sorry it's okay
and uh yeah super stoked thank you so
much for doing this no thank you for
having me and
you know well i'm sure i'll see you soon
because you're my neighbor
yeah she's out cold look at wendy look
at you yeah
she's so fat she's so sweet
[Laughter]
did i tell you or what that was just a
lot of
good old-fashioned fun man um
plus she's my neighbor how about that
and you
are my friend for sticking around to the
very end
you know what let's do it this week the
street team deal
grab a screenshot and and post it
tagging chanel west coast
let her know that you enjoyed the
podcast that you're a fan
give her some love man because she's
pretty cool and
so are you thank you again for watching
yeah
dude i mean listening